collège visitation la berrière
géographie troisième année aujourd'hui
les risques naturels en support de cet
exposé le syllabus de géographie page 38
à 42 et la place catastrophe naturelle
c'est uniquement disponible pour la 14e
édition on appelle un risque tout danger
menaçant un groupe humain lorsque
l'événement se produit on parle alors de
catastrophe les risques naturels sont
évidemment d'origine naturelle
contrairement aux risques anthropique
qui sont d'origine humaine
attention tout événement naturel qui a
lieu n'est pas forcément une catastrophe
par exemple un séismes survenant dans
une zone inhabitée est un événement
naturel lié à un risque naturel et non
une catastrophe puisqu'il n'y a pas de
victime mais il n'y a pas de dégâts aux
infrastructures que l'homme a crié le
risque naturel et donc une probabilité
dont la réalisation est aléatoire elle
peut survenir ou pas probable mais
difficilement prévisibles et donc
potentiellement catastrophiques pour
l'homme
le climat est sont des règlements sont à
l'origine de nombreux risques
atmosphérique liée au phénomène
météorologique
tout d'abord il ya les sécheresses les
sécheresses ce sont des périodes où il
ne pleut pas suffisamment les
précipitations ne sont pas suffisamment
importante
ceci peut nuire aux cultures que l'homme
pratiques et donc ça peut conduire à des
famines importante et donc des
conséquences catastrophiques
on a aussi les inondations qui sont
souvent dues aux crues des différents
cours d'eau est ce qu'une crue c'est le
moment de l'année où le volume de l'eau
est le plus important et ça vient il ya
tellement de aucun spam en lots sont
hors du lit du cours d'eau et bien
parfois dans les zones habitées inondé
les activités humaines et donc d'être
catastrophique ça va causer du dégâts
matériels mais aussi ça peut causer la
mort de plusieurs personnes
enfin nous avons les ouragans qui sont
des tempêtes violentes qui se forme
générale
man au-dessus des océans chaud et qui se
déplace très vite les vents ils sont
très violents souvent les ouragans sont
confinés combinée à des raz-de-marée en
raison de déplacements doux et d'air
qu'ils occasionnent les unes aux
brigands sont des phénomènes
relativement prévisible est donc attendu
mais ce qui n'exclut pas le risque de
catastrophe pour l'homme les risques
géophysique comprennent les séismes mais
le volcanisme
en fait ce sont tous les risques qui
sont liées à la structure de la terre
les séismes occasionne de nombreux
dégâts lorsqu'ils surviennent dans des
zones avec des densités de population
important les populations qui résident
dans les grandes villes ou sur les 8
euro menacés comme par exemple la
californie où l'asie centrale vivent
toujours dans la crainte que survienne
un big one
c'est à dire un séisme d'une grande
magnitude plus de 8 sur l'échelle de
richter et qui provoquerait dès lors un
très grand nombre de victimes on peut
évidemment surveiller les risques
sismiques et plusieurs moyens peuvent
être mis en laye en oeuvre pour réduire
les conséquences d'un séisme
la sensibilisation des populations le
respect des normes de construction
permettent de réduire l'ampleur des
dégâts toutefois ces mesures ont un coût
et demande une réelle volonté d'action
de la part des acteurs statio ce n'est
pas toujours le cas
ensuite nous avons les volcans qui sont
des risques importants mais qui ne sont
pas les mêmes en fonction du type de
volcans les volcans exclu explosifs sont
beaucoup plus dangereux que les volcans
effusif vous avez ici l'image d'un
volcan explosif qui crée un nuage de
fumée et de cendres très important
les volcans explosif connaît ces
éruptions soudaine très dangereux de
parler projection qu'elles occasionnent
les volcans effusif sont plus calmes et
correspondent à des coulées de la
fouille de plus prévisible est longue
moins dangereux les populations peuvent
agir pour prendre leurs dispositions
évidemment et de plus les volcans
explosif et en moins fréquemment en
activité ils surprennent la population
lorsqu'il entre en éruption mais ces
risques volcaniques sont néanmoins de
mieux en mieux connus et les volcans les
plus dangereux sont sous surveillance
constante ce qui permet d'éviter de
nombreuses catastrophes
certaines techniques voit également le
jour comme le guidage des coulées de
lave qui permet d'éviter les zones
habitées ensuite on a tous les risques
qui sont liées au terrain d'un bien sûr
les chutes comme des chutes de pierres
qui sont des détachements de petits
éléments d'une paroi rocheuse
mais aussi l'éboulement qui est là
vraiment est quasi l'effondrement d'une
paroisse complète donc ça peut être très
dangereux surtout quand ça revient en
zone habitée ensuite on a les
glissements de terrain qui est vraiment
le déplacement latéral de toute une
partie du terrain ça et souvent quand
les sols sont boues contiennent beaucoup
d'eau après des précipitations
importantes à ce moment là ils ont moins
de résistance et il s'écoule plus
facilement et ensuite on allait couler
comme les coulées de boue mais aussi
découler rouge sur le rocher
ils sont vraiment un déversement de
matériaux plus ou moins neuf c'est à
dire plus - liquide ou en tout cas
plastique qui vont se déplacer qui vont
entraîner dans leur cou les différents
résidus ou différents déchets différents
éléments de de nos constructions et qui
n'ont connu au casone encore plus de
dégâts ça arrive évidemment avec des
précipitations importantes quand le sol
celui qui fit littéralement ensuite on a
deux autres phénomènes qui sont toujours
liés à la nature est dangereux pour
l'homme les invasions animal comme les
invasions de criquets sauterelles
principalement d'elle en afrique vont
causer des dégâts importants aux
différentes cultures et on a aussi bien
sûr que les risques liés aux maladies
aux des justes qui vont près des
épidémies donc une vague de maladies
importantes au sein d'une population
alors actuellement on peut penser par
exemple à l'épidémie du sida
et quand cela dépasse et de l'échelle
d'un pays où d'un territoire que ça
touche vraiment cazine l'ensemble du
monde et l'ensemble d'un continent en
particulier on va parler de pandémie
voilà cette vidéo est terminée une
petite préparation pour voir si vous
avez bien été attentif et si vous avez
bien tout compris ce que je vais vous
demander c'est sur une feuille de cours
de réaliser le petit la petite carte
mentale qui est ici donc voilà on part
des risques naturels au centre et g
les quatre types de risques que l'on
peut rencontrer vous allez pour chacun
de ces risques
créer des nouvelles branches par exemple
comme ceux ci et vous allez indiqué ben
ce que vous avez vu dans la vidéo par
exemple dans les risques géophysique
il ya les volcans désolé c'est difficile
d'écrire éléphants voilà vous avez
complété ainsi de suite pour les
différents risques dont on a parlé dans
la vidéo vous allez complété il vraiment
cette carte mentale en créant chaque
fois des branches différentes avec des
différents risques qui existent et vous
allez en plus surligner ou souligné les
risques qui sont présents en belgique
donc si vous estimez que en belgique il
ya des risques de volcanisme et bien
vous suivrez nier vous soulignez ou
surligner volcan voilà si vous avez des
questions je suis disponible bien sûr
aux récréations ou dans la cour mais
aussi par dl sylvain drame heure d'un
mot gmail.com bonne fin de journée